hey youtubers is Charlie so even more
new thor ragnarok stuff learned from the
set thor post-credits scene where they
meet dr. strange this is going to be a
breakdown of what's going on because
loki is part of that too this is
actually a pretty big deal it's one
thing to see them walking around on set
but to reveal a detail like this is just
like dropping a bomb in the middle of
the fandom so at some point during thor
ragnarok or at some point during dr.
strange we will see them meet up and I
know that Thor is holding this so like
very clearly he's going to talk to dr.
strange about the infinity gems but loki
looks like he's here too because he's
sitting in plain clothes with thor so
for all of you who were hoping for a
loki dr. strange meet up on screen it
looks like we're going to get it way
sooner than you ever expected and if you
haven't read the comics just to make
this clear loki is a magic user
just like dr. strange now the type of
magic that they practice is a little bit
different in the comics but you can
understand how the movies would just
combine those two things like all magic
users tap into the same type of energy
in fact Loki's mother
Frigga or you know Thor and Loki's
mother Frigga is the one that taught him
to use magic that's why he's so close to
her a lot of people actually felt like
it was one of those parental things were
like one parent favors the other child
so like Frigga liked Loki more than she
liked Thor and Odin like Thor more than
he liked Loki those very Shakespearean
that's kind of the way they spun the
first Thor movie but they've slowly kind
of moved away from that but you get the
idea when you watch Thor the dark world
you get the idea that Loki really loved
his mother when the Dark Elves killed
her that's what turned him back onto
Thor side even though we got that tease
at the end where he's like okay I'm
gonna impersonate Odin and have all the
fun that I want in Asgard but from the
looks of it it looks like this is
happening towards the end of the Thor
story like by the time that Loki is back
working with Thor because of whatever
happens during Thor Ragnarok so for the
sake of argument we'll say that Thanos
does something really terrible loki
learns that what he's planning on doing
is worse than what life will be like
under thor so he's like okay i might as
well help thor in the avengers now i'll
help him find dr. strange it would make
sense that one magic user would know how
to find another magic user so i know we
haven't seen the Doctor Strange movie
yet but the sanctum sanctorum
I'm like the place that he's looking for
that address that's on his little card
there can only be accessed through
magical means you can't just walk up and
knock on the door so I like the idea
that we're gonna see Loki practice a
little bit of magic
during thor ragnarok to like let me open
the door here so you can knock and meet
your new Avenger friend because
depending on when this scene happens in
the timeline Doctor Strange will have
already been aware of the Avengers
already be trying to help them but
presumably it's happening sometime after
the end of Doctor Strange because that
movie is coming in November so like even
if they attach this to the end of Doctor
Strange if they're filming a Thor
post-credit scene to attach to the end
of Doctor Strange which I don't think
they're doing he would already still be
sorcerer supreme so what I'm thinking is
is that this scene here where Thor and
Loki meet Doctor Strange is actually
going to be like a mid credit sequence
at the end of Thor Ragnarok that teases
Avengers infinity war but if you guys
saw my last movie I talked about how
actually it's Black Panther is the next
movie in the timeline after Thor
Ragnarok so I think they're just
compressing the timeline so like the end
of Black Panther will also be like in
the same moments as the end of Thor
Ragnarok so either way I think we could
probably agree that this is happening at
the end of Thor Ragnarok or at least
around there in the timeline I don't
think they're actually shooting footage
for infinity war but this would explain
how Loki ends up working with the
Avengers
during infinity war because he'd be one
of the only people who could help Thor
find Doctor Strange Doctor Strange has a
much more cosmic understanding of the
you know the ramifications of what
Thanos is trying to do what could
possibly happen he this has a broader
understanding of existence than Thor but
I feel like most people understand more
about the universe than Thor that's
always kind of been the characterization
he is very smart very good warrior below
key has always known so much more like
Loki knows all the in and out points
from Asgard like there's only a couple
different places that you can travel out
of Asgard unknown so Thor not the
cleverest or sneakiest of Asgardians
that's why he always has this look on
his face angry and confused but let me
know in the comments do you think that
this Thor Loki Doctor Strange meetup is
going to be a mid credit sequence for
the end of Thor Ragnarok and if you
don't know the difference between a mid
credit sequence in a post-credits
sequence their kind
the same thing but not really a mid
credit sequence happens like at the very
tail end of a movie
they have like a version of the credits
with a bunch of graphics looks really
flashy lay it's like right after the end
of the movie you know then this pops up
like oh it's like a little tag at the
end with the same characters from that
movie the traditional post credits
scenes that you see in Avengers films is
always like another group of characters
from a different film so if we see a
thor ragnarok post-credit scene it might
be like the guardians of the galaxy or
like a different group of characters
that were really a part of thor ragnarok
but by the time thor ragnarok drops in
theaters will have already seen most of
the phase 3 movies so anything's up for
grabs for thor ragnarok post-credit
scene but i feel like at that point they
will be pushing Avengers infinity war
stuff as hard as possible but this is so
awesome they filmed this outdoor scene
in Brisbane so this is doubling for New
York City
looks like he's standing like right
outside where the sanctum sanctorum is
going to be obviously there's going to
be a lot of CG because Brisbane doesn't
look anything like the streets of New
York so those changes in post-production
but they took a whole bunch more
pictures on set there's a bit of an
easter egg here for Tiger YTD films so
this character here is actually somebody
that appeared in the thor ragnarok
comic-con footage his name is Barry they
shot this funny documentary that I've
talked about in a couple of my other
videos just as a funny way to explain
what Thor was doing during civil war
like look he was just living with this
person named Barry
trying to figure out who the purple man
and the chair was what was going on with
the glove that he wore with all the
jewels in it just you know like a really
funny way to say hey this is what's
going to be happening during thor
ragnarok but now it actually looks like
Barry really is in the movie like this
funny character that they invented so
I'll be interested to see how he works
in but he might be like the Darcy type
character from Thor the dark world she
was kind of in the movie as a way to
offer some comedic relief and they've
been teasing the thor ragnarok is going
to be one of the funniest Marvel movies
so far even though technically it's not
a comedy I just did a video where Mark
Ruffalo talks about it as like a buddy
roadtrip comedy I'll link that at the
end of this but I'm just really excited
for this they're getting super comic
book II with the movies so if you like
them doing really weird funny stuff you
are going to be blown away by this
but speaking of really funny weird stuff
James Gunn posted some concept art that
appeared in
the guardians of the galaxy comic-con
footage so I'm gonna do a video for that
next but you see them fighting a space
monster you get a better look at dancing
baby Groot but this monster is actually
part of the plot of guardians of the
galaxy too so I'll explain that when I
post that video tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get that and there is a new
round of the giveaway that's going on
now - all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so new dancing baby Groot posting
later tonight well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
Mark Ruffalo Thor Ragnarok behind the
scenes video where he talks about hella
and you can click here for my daredevil
season 3 teaser trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys at night
you